well I thought at least I think that all
of us who in some way are anglo-saxon
have to realize that there are other
ideas around and that they can be added
to our own thinking and vocabulary and
that we have to be open-minded towards
others now that doesn't mean that we
give up cultural basic assumptions such
as human rights such as the rights of
women and children because some of these
basic assumptions in our societies we
must not give up and we have to continue
I think arguing and illustrating how
they benefit society when you pursue
them but that doesn't mean that you
cannot collaborate with countries far
away which are inspired by a global
community that is all the time learning
from each other I mean from different
corners of the world we don't have to
give up our identity even if we open up
to other cultures and other assumptions
well I think the basic thing we
identified was that in the 1980s we have
come so far in seeing the dramatic and
emerging trends of the planet being
affected by our human activities that we
for the first time in human history
realized that we are not only
responsible for each other those who are
living today but that we are responsible
to take care of the opportunities for
future generations
that was the basic I think content of
that observation and about the concept
of sustainable development that we need
to also consider the future of coming
generations you know in the 50 hundred
years ago people thought about future
generations with regard to their own son
or daughter taking over the firm but
they didn't have to think in terms of
the global aspects of our footprints
without their mind the future choices of
generations unborn that's I think is the
basic part of that concept